ja ganze drei monate krieg in der
ukraine und der krieg tobt immer wilder
im osten des landes geht seit etwa sechs
wochen die russische offensive voran und
sie kommt voran russland in extremster
zerstörungskraft nimmt hier immer mehr
städte ein und wir haben neue aufnahmen
aus der stadt lima die gestern entweder
teils oder komplett an russland gefallen
ist und diese aufnahmen zeigen dass das
gas stadtzentrum zeigen ein großer staat
überall dort häuser und was wir gleich
sehen ist ja kaum zu glauben es sind wir
sehen hier die sechs personen das im
thermo bayerische waffen das sind die
rosen bomben stärkste bomben die dort
von russland eingesetzt werden ich mach
das nochmal kurz zurück also mörderische
waffen die bei ihrer explosionen nicht
nur den sprengstoff nutzen den sie haben
sondern auch ein gemisch von von
chemikalien erst in die luft lassen die
dann
ist es noch einmal an die dann entzündet
werden von einer zweiten explosion und
somit sozusagen diese chemikalien
zusammen mit der luft ein mega explosion
entwickeln wir sehen dass hier und dann
dort massive zerstörungen anrichten das
ist die stadt lima wir schauen uns
einmal die karte an die man hier in der
nähe in der nähe von sedo netz von
slavia im osten der ukraine und wer so
dass mal ein zu zeichnen diese region
nur hans die läuft hier lang das ist die
region die russland als allererstes
jetzt einen möchte hier gibt es
tatsächlich massive vorstöße einmal aus
partner in die richtung und einmal die
haben gerade gesagt aus liman in die
richtung und man versucht hier in zivil
donetzk wonach mehrere tausend
ukrainische soldaten ja sich verteidigen
versucht man einen neuen kessel sowie in
mario pohl zu entwickeln und scheint
damit auch leider voranzukommen die
ukraine kann sich wenn auch stark
verteidigen aber nicht so sehr
verteidigen dass russlands formation
dort zum erliegen kommt nicht nur nicht
nur lehmann wurde gestern eingenommen
sondern auch eine weitere stadt mit etwa
8000 einwohnern ehemals die in der nähe
von jeweils über liegt auch das ein
wichtiger ein wichtiger hab sozusagen
für die für den verkehr in der ost
ukraine was machen die okeraner die
ukraine versuchen sich zu wehren nach
allem nach allen möglichkeiten wir sehen
hier ukrainische artillerie die
russische nachschub laster zerstört wir
sehen ob diese völlig zerstörten städte
dort das sind alles menschen da gibt es
keine zivilisten mehr da ist russland
ein gefallen und wird jetzt hier von der
ukraine aus der luft aus beschossen bz
also vom boden geschossen mit artillerie
beschossen
und das ganze wird von drohnen
koordiniert wenn wir uns das mal ansehen
auch hier ein waldstück wo russische
artillerie und russische lkw angegriffen
werden und völlig zerstört werden dem
blutzoll den russland bezahlt er ist
riesig der ist wirklich unfassbar riesig
es sind zwischen 100 und 200 russischer
soldaten die am tag am tag sterben hier
im osten der ukraine und trotzdem ist es
so dass putin nicht aufhört dass putin
sie weiter vorantreibt das problem aus
allen ecken russlands und eben der
sogenannten volksrepublik hier
kanonenfutter zusammensucht um die
panzer zu betreiben die arterien zu
betreiben und weiter vorzurücken das
gelingt ihnen weiterhin wie wir gesagt
haben auch die jetzt gerade mehrere
artillerie geschütze der russischen
armee explodiert der ganze wald brennt
hier trotzdem trotz dieser massiven
verluste gelingt dass russland weiter
vorzurücken was kann die ukrainer noch
dagegen tun sie wartet weiterhin auf
waffen des westens sie wartet auf
schwere waffen vor allem aus europa und
während wir von der bundesregierung
weiter hören man liefert keine schwere
waffen das tun die anderen auch nicht
sehen wir jetzt dass sogar frankreich
sogar frankreich erste schwere waffen in
die ukraine liefert hier erste aufnahmen
des esa das ist ein mobile haubitze die
auf einem lkw transportiert wird das
video ist ein bisschen fancy gemacht das
machen die ukraine so um eben auch die
moral zu steigern aber wie sie in hier
die 155 millimeter artillerie die sich
schnell von einem ort zum anderen
bewegen kann erstmals in aktion in der
ukraine nachdem die ukrainischen
soldaten im ausland entweder in
frankreich oder in polen einen monat
lang ausgebildet worden sind sie jetzt
mit diesen
haubitzen sie sich bewegen können
sozusagen im krieg im einsatz also auch
frankreich liefert schwere waffen so wie
viele andere länder westliche schwere
waffen nicht so deutschland und wir
gucken uns am ende noch eines an was den
ukrainern hoffentlich etwas hoffnung
gibt die ersten aufnahmen jemals von der
sogenannten switchblade 600 das ist eine
amerikanische kamikaze drohne die vor
einem monat angekündigt wurde die jetzt
offenbar endlich in der ukraine
angekommen ist wir sehen hier
das verschiedene drogen das ganze film
hier vorne ich versuche das mal ein
zeichen hier vorne haben wir das ziel da
haben wir einen russischen panzer ein t
72 panzer der von einer drohne hier oben
anvisiert wird und von einer anderen
dann gleich angegriffen wird das ganze
ist ein bisschen verwirrend wir gucken
uns das aber mal an wie dass wir das
ganze läuft wir haben also diesen panzer
dort wir haben wir die verschiedenen
parameter die man sieht von der drohne
wie lange die in der luft das beispiel
weil beispielsweise wie hoch sie ist wir
sehen hier auf der auf der rechten seite
sehen wir ihre höhe in metern sozusagen
welchem winkel sie hat das ist für den
für den schützen sehr wichtig und da
unten sehen wir jetzt grün eingekreist
zum ersten mal das ziel da sehen wir
dass da also ein grünes direkt um das
ziel herum und jetzt wird diese drohne
bisschen weise eine drohne sich auf
diesen panzer zu bewegen und es sind
immer relativ erschreckende aufnahmen
aber auch beeindruckende aufnahmen jetzt
haben wir den treffer gesehen von einer
drohne und wir sehen jetzt von einer
anderen drohne danach tief erstreckende
aufnahmen weil man tatsächlich bis zum
moment des einschlags sieht wie sich
diese kamikaze drohne auf ihr ziel
zubewegt das heißt da ist eine kamera
drinnen die sendet bis zur letzten
sekunde die bilder an die übertragungs
station an den empfänger sozusagen und
wir sehen jetzt
sozusagen hier den russischen panzer
t 72 3 und wir sehen wie auf dem panzer
soldaten darauf stehen die also eine
sekunde etwa nach diesem bild dann von
der drohne getroffen werden von dieser
kamikaze drohne getroffen werden und wir
haben das feuer gesehen dass der panzer
dann in flammen aufgeht auf diese
kamikaze drohnen haben die ukraine sehr
gehofft angeblich sollen ist 100 dieser
schweren switchblade 600 drohnen seien
und etwa 1000 von leichten switchback
300 drohen diese kamikaze drohen so
extrem wichtig für die ukraine um eben
den gegner anzugreifen weil das eben
hightech drohnen sind wie man gesehen
hat die ihr ziel erst über kreisen dann
genau gucken gesichter zivilisten in der
nähe oder nicht und wenn nicht eben bei
bedarf direkt auf das ziel angreifen
können so die situation genau nach drei
monaten krieg in der ukraine putin rückt
weiter vor aber er bezahlt einen extrem
hohen blutzoll
[Musik]